えー実は…
洗濯物が嫌いすぎて業者さんにやってもらってます
はじめしゃちょーです
あのー心霊スポット色々行ったんですけども
案外ですね身近なところに
すっげー心霊スポットっていうのが隠れているようでして
ご覧くださいあちら
正式名称は違うと思うんすけど
なんかトトロの森って言われてるらしくて
これゆまおが言ってたんだよね
めっちゃやべー心霊スポットあるんよめんちゃんって言ってて
めんちゃんめんちゃん　めんちゃんあそこ本当にやばいんだよって言って
で、あそこがなんか本当に怖いらしくて
中に祠(ほこら)があるみたいな話を聞いております
行きますか
カメラマン）行きますか
はじめ）うわーほらなんかこういう感じで奉ってあるみたい
カメラマン）本当だ
はじめ）怖いねー
カメラマン）怖いですねー
はじめ）こっから行くか　ついてこい
カメラマン）えーちょ　急！急！
カメラマン）危ない
はじめ）わちゃちゃう
はじめ）川渡んないとダメっぽいすね
はじめ）うわっほらでもやばい、やばいよ
カメラマン）確かに
はじめ）ちょっと今回怖すぎてチキって早い時間に来てしまいました
カメラマン）待って靴間違えた絶対
はじめ）いや
はじめ）あーありありあり適正適正
カメラマン）ｗｗｗ　適正ですかこれ
はじめ）行きまーす
カメラマン）はーい
はじめ）うわー冷てー無理だー
カメラマン）あっ！終わった
はじめ）はははｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）ねぇ、靴そこで脱いでくればよかったのに
カメラマン）あ、そうだ
はじめ）これすごいビビるよ多分りょう君
カメラマン）そんなすごいんですか？
はじめ）すごい　いくよいくよ
はじめ）２
カメラマン）２
はじめ）いやちょっと怖いよねー　ちょっ気持ちでいきますわ
はじめ）じゃあ行ってきます
カメラマン）はい　頑張ってください
はじめ）待って本当に深い　やばい
カメラマン）俺そっちに行けない…
はじめ）待って本当に
カメラマン）はじめさんの足でそこって俺の首あたりじゃないすか？
はじめ）それは盛りすぎｗ
カメラマン）え…
はじめ）いやこれ帰れるかなぁ
はじめ）よくわかるねこの距離からってか
カメラマン）確かに
はじめ）いやー待ってすごいねぇ
カメラマン）す…やばいですね
カメラマン）急に心スポ感出てきてますよ
カメラマン）え…
カメラマン）あっ　な、な、なんすかそれ
はじめ）日焼け止めだ
カメラマン）あ、日焼け止めか
はじめ）怖ー待って本当にやばい　ちょっ待って
カメラマン）え？
はじめ）ほら
カメラマン）本当だうわっなんすかこれ
はじめ）行こ？
カメラマン）行きましょ
はじめ）上に神社があるみたいですね
はじめ）なんせ怖いのこの道よ道　ほら
はじめ）なんか情報によるとここで誰かが足を引っ張られたっていうことを聞きました
カメラマン）え？今ドットって
カメラマン）えっ何？なんすかなんすか
カメラマン）あ、あれですか
カメラマン）え？ちょちょちょちょ
はじめ）ははははｗｗｗｗ
カメラマン）絶対はじめさんじゃないすかー
カメラマン）ねぇねぇ！肩トンやめてくださいよ
はじめ）びっくりした人かと思った今
カメラマン）あっ
カメラマン）こえー
はじめ）祠(ほこら)です
はじめ）恋愛スポットかもしれませんね
カメラマン）ふふふｗｗ
はじめ）うわっ人いる！
カメラマン）え？え？え？え？え？
はじめ）嘘、嘘ｗ嘘だよｗｗ
カメラマン）怖い怖い怖い待って
カメラマン）すごい今怖くなっちゃった
はじめ）はははｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）すっげーなんか左から視線を感じるんだけど
はじめ）見て鳥肌
カメラマン）あ、本当だ
カメラマン）寒気がやば
はじめ）やばい待ってお札貼ってある
はじめ）見て見て見て　ここほら
カメラマン）どれどれ　なんのやつだ
はじめ）いやーなおきだけは絶対許されねーこれは
カメラマン）本当
はじめ）もう行こもう行こ
カメラマン）はい行きましょ
‪はじめ）怖すぎてまじ無理
カメラマン）怖い怖い怖い
はじめ）え？え？待って待って待って
カメラマン）え？待って待って今
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング　ホラーVer.】
砂嵐の後って怖いよね
はじめ）あ？何？
カメラマン）石石石
カメラマン）ポンって
はじめ）投げた？
カメラマン）投げてない投げてないだってほら両手がカメラと　ライト
はじめ）待ってまじやばいまじやばい